[Music]
and welcome to the 24th annual dr.
Martin Luther King jr. breakfast
celebration my name is Karina Sedona I'm
currently a junior in the department of
management science and it is an honor to
be your mistress of ceremonies this
morning I would like to begin by
thanking president Charles and vest and
mrs. Rebecca vest for hosting this
morning's event Thank You president mrs.
best and I would like to welcome Leslie
Baskerville Esquire our keynote speaker
it is a pleasure to have you with us
this morning I would like to thank the
members of the dr. Martin Luther King
jr. celebration committee who have
helped make this morning's event
possible please stand as I call your
names
Corinna Claudia professor Phillip clay
Maureen Costello
Ronald critchlow Dean and David Shaw
professor Jerome Friedman Reverend Jane
Gould professor Kenneth Hale professor
Wesley Harris Dean Arnold Henderson
junior event Lane Professor Philip
Morrison professor Melissa Nobles
Richard O'Bryant Paul Pavano Robert
sails Laurie Smith
professor cardinal ward dr. Clarence
Williams and the co-chairs of the
committee
professor Michael Feld and Dean Leo
Osgood jr. thank you all
also I would like to welcome the dr.
Martin Luther King jr. visiting
professors and this year's Leadership
Award recipients we will now begin this
morning celebration with an invocation
by dr. Alice Brown Collins advisor to
the black Christian fellowship at MIT
dr. Brown Collins
good morning I'm a black preacher but
this morning we would like for you to
hear the voice of Martin Luther King
many of you are familiar with his
speeches and his writings but most of us
have not heard him pray in particular
kinds of ways and this morning
I'm going to ask you around the tables
if you will hold each other's hands and
if you wish you may bow your heads as we
listen to our brother Martin pray this
morning Oh God our Heavenly Father we
thank thee for this gold and privilege
to worship thee the only true God of the
universe we come today to praise thee
grateful that thou has kept us through
the long night of the past and ushered
us into the challenge of the present and
the bright hope of the future we are
mindful Oh God that man cannot save
himself for man is not the measure of
things and humanity is not God bound by
our chains of sin we know we need a
Savior we thank thee O God for the
spiritual nature of man we are in nature
but we live above nature help us never
to let anybody or any condition pull us
so low as to cause us to hate give us
strength to love our enemies and to do
good to those who despitefully use us
and persecute us we thank thee for thy
church founded upon thy word that
challenges us to do more than sing and
pray but to go out and work as though
the very answer to our prayers dependent
upon us and not upon thee then finally
help us to realize that man and woman
was created to shine like stars and live
through all eternity keep us we pray in
perfect peace help us to walk together
to pray together to sing together and to
live together until that day when all of
God's children black
white red and yellow will rejoice in one
common band of humanity in the kingdom
of our Lord and of our Savior God we
pray amen
thank you dr. Brown Collins before we
partake in our breakfast this morning
the MIT gospel choir will sing a
selection Erin winters will you please
assembly require
good morning we are the MIT gospel choir
or a subset thereof and praise the Lord
this morning we're going to sing to you
a song called the Lord is great we hope
it is a blessing to you and thank you
for attention
we we our
[Music]
[Applause]
he's waiting to be plays the Lord is
[Music]
[Applause]
excuse me we're going to continue our
program I hope you've all enjoyed your
breakfast and are ready to proceed we
will continue with the reflection on the
life and legacy of dr. King
presented by Michonne Donaldson class of
2001 and Cassandra Strudwick a graduate
student in the Department of Civil and
environmental engineering Michonne
good morning my name is Michonne
Donelson and I'm a freshman in the
chemical engineering where do we go from
here this is a question that I would
like to address this morning many times
in our society people often discuss
issues about affirmative action we tend
to operate to mend or ways to end it or
we even present imaginative ideas today
we still offer possible solutions to
guarantee equal rights in equality so
that leads me to the question that dr.
King asked in 1967 where do we go from
here
chaos or community which was the title
of his last book as we examine this
year's theme the same old bone the
campaign against affirmative action let
us examine where this idea of the same
old bone originated back in 1863 with
the abolition of slavery the Negro man
did not have the opportunities for
economic advancement in society it was
hard for them to get jobs because they
would look down upon because of the deep
rich melanin they possessed and their
former plight is slaves similar negative
perceptions lived on through dr. King's
day and well into our era dr. King was
one of the most powerful leaders in
American history he was the type of man
who meditated on the teachings and the
life of Jesus Christ remembered always
that the nonviolent movement sought
justice and Reconciliation walked and
talked in a matter of love for God is
love prayed to be used by God in order
that all men and women might live free
sacrifice personal wishes and order that
all people might be free and sought to
perform regular service for others and
for the world dr. King faithfully led
the civil rights movement for several
years and he strongly believed that in
the Equality of all people he always had
a dream that one day people will be
judged by the content of their character
and
by the color of their skin back during
the civil rights era african-americans
were appointed to significant jobs the
Negro felt as if they were always being
tossed the same old bone but now it was
only being done with courtesy in other
words black people were being treated
the same way but only in the dignified
fashion it seems as if over the years
nothing has really changed dr. King felt
that a society that has done something
against the Negro for hundreds of years
must do something special for him he
felt as if all people to be allowed
equal opportunities an affirmative
action sought to achieve his dreams
affirmative action is not preference for
race over race it is preferential
treatment for full inclusion and equal
opportunities for for democracy dr. King
had all of this as part of his dream and
his assassination should not be the end
of his dream or the fight for equality
now let us come back to the present
today anti affirmative action policies
are continuously being passed this
process only destroys the method by
which equality is achieved Martin Luther
King jr. once said the integration is
the mutual sharing of power white
America must realize that justice for
black people cannot be achieved without
radical changes in the structure of our
society this is a multiracial nation
where all groups of people are dependent
on each other their power that I
mentioned and their power that dr. King
referred to it is educational power it
is financial power and it is social
empowerment will we ever be allowed to
enter the temple of power to drink from
the world of opportunity or are we to
continue banging on the glass ceiling
while the majority continues to maintain
the power if dr. King was still alive I
think that he would say the only true
way to achieve equality is for our
nation to share that power and unite is
one so my final question for you today
is where do we go from here or are we
going to be continuing to be tossed the
same
in one of dr. King's last speeches he
said we are all caught in an inescapable
network of mutuality tied in a single
garment of destiny whatever affects one
affects all indirectly no man is an
island private in himself every man is a
piece of a continent a part of the main
structure one man's death diminishes us
because we are all involved in mankind
and therefore we are to never let dr.
King's dream die and continue to strive
for the ultimate goal of freedom and
equality how long will it take for us
african-americans Native Americans
Hispanics asian-americans Caucasians and
all nationalities of people to fulfill
his dream and become the most powerful
force in the world thank you
[Applause]
thank you Michonne for those
thought-provoking remarks we will now
proceed with Cassandra's Strudwick
Sandra
good morning
my name is Cassandra Strudwick and I'm a
graduate student in the Department of
Civil and environmental engineering
if the postmaster could reach the
heavens this is what I would send dear
dr. King I had read your biography and
her stories of your trials and
tribulations for my parents and
grandparents who bore witness to then
justices and fought the same battles
with you as a member of a generation
only reads of your work and your dream I
often wonder what this nation would be
like if your dream had been fulfilled
for it surely has not been at this time
dr. King since the time you were taken
from us we have become a nation of
confused people as we continue the
plight to become equal to be treated
equal as a race in business and
education we have gone from Negro to
black to african-american from black
business to minority business to
historically underutilized to
disadvantaged all these labels and
designations yet we have never been
labeled equal while the injustice is
still prevalent many people believe that
affirmative action is detrimental e
contagious because they're ignorant to
what affirmative action really means
affirmative action as I understand it
means that a competent University will
take positive steps to ensure it does
not discriminate all guidelines and
mandates regarding affirmative action
clearly state that candidates must be
qualified affirmative action simply
encourages the development of ways to
seek out and promote well-qualified
candidates it would therefore seem to me
that affirmative action should not be
viewed as a crutch but as a way of
alleviating discrimination if an entire
race were to enter a marathon 300 years
after another they would first had to
perform some impossible feat in order to
catch up with their fellow runners
affirmative action simply provides a
level track and good running shoes it
does not guarantee first place
furthermore affirmative action does not
lift responsibility from black people as
a race as we climb the layers of success
we must pull others up with us we must
make opportunities available for our
brothers and sisters to resew same
we towers we strive to reach we must not
be afraid to love each other to help
each other to be proud to be black to be
proud to be descendants of a strength
even in the midst of an relented
struggle dr. King what would you have us
do today to get back to achieving your
Jing what would you direct us to do we
assemble the Masters of March again
would you ask no demand that our black
leaders redirect their causes from those
tough monetary achievements to social
and economic advancements for all
citizens should we look for dynamic
influential in global orient an
individual to provide leadership in
project oriented goals for affirmative
action programs or should we each pursue
our own dreams on an individual basis
become a citizen who makes a difference
how can we achieve a dream that's only
remembered during the shortest and
coldest month of the year a dream that
will require entire nation to dance
together to a musical tune thatis Inuits
life of faith hope and love so next year
we may rejoice and not in a dream
deferred but immeasurable advances and
in mighty that are more important than
what's in the breakfast menu and
throughout this entire nation what would
you have us do don't despair dr. King as
history unfolds one page at a time one
day you will find our race in the first
chapter and not in the appendix as
solemn onlookers with the spirit of love
strength and commitment your legacy
continues to breathe life into black men
and women we're left to rap for you as
saints and sinners with all of our good
deeds and beds all of our struggles and
successes and yes all of our dreams and
through faith and perseverance we will
continue the armed were marched to a
unified nation of people and your dream
will be achieved and then dr. King thank
God Almighty we will live free at last
as I reflected on these issues I wanted
somebody to address them then I realized
that I am somebody and that you have
passed a torch ahran to those of us who
are coming on the scene we should be
thrilled to have this opportunity to
give life to your dream I know that I am
very truly yours
Kassandra Strudwick thank you
thank you Michonne and Casandra for
those inspiring words I now have the
honor of introducing the 15th president
of the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology dr. Charles M best doctor
vest is also the chairman of the board
of directors of gem the National
Consortium for graduate degrees for
minorities in engineering and science
incorporated this is only one of the
many significant roles dr. vest has
played on a national level to achieve
full inclusion for minorities in higher
education president vest will present
the recipients of the 1997-98 Martin
Luther King jr. Leadership Awards for
alumni faculty and student or student
groups president best
Thank You Karina for the last seven
years or so I've always looked forward
to these breakfasts or before that we
held them in other formats a great
opportunity to reflect on something
incredibly important but I have to tell
you I'm starting not to look forward to
them anymore because the wisdom and
eloquence of these young people make me
feel very small when I come up here I'm
just terrific ly proud of these folks
thank them again please
I do want very much to thank all of you
for joining us this morning to
participate in this annual and very
important celebration I'm especially
pleased that we are joined this morning
by many members of the Cambridge
community beyond the boundaries of our
campus including city councilor
Henriette Davis are you here miss Davis
welcome thank you for being with us it
is seriously a great privilege for me to
share the podium on this important
occasion and it is an even greater
privilege to have this annual
opportunity to present the Martin Luther
King Leadership Awards in the same
spirit that Cambridge is owned Tip
O'Neill used to observe that all
politics is local I would like to
suggest you this morning that all great
social change is personal collective
action and general social progress is
that its root the result of individual
leadership individual example individual
courage and conviction the winners of
the Martin Luther King jr. Leadership
Award are selected not simply for their
personal achievements although those
certainly are considerable but for the
effect that they have had on others
around them they are selected not only
because they exemplify the ideals of dr.
King but because they have succeeded in
transmitting those ideals to others we
are indeed fortunate to have each of
these people in our midst the first of
this year's award goes to dr. Linda
Jordan who is currently also a Martin
Luther King jr. visiting associate
professor in mi t--'s department of
chemistry
as many of you know very well dr. Jordan
has a passion for biochemistry
she has an equal passion for inspiring
excellence and perseverance in her
students and she has made it a special
mission to foster the growth of
minorities and women in science in
America dr. Jordan has been recognized
and celebrated at the national level for
her work in science and for her
leadership in encouraging the younger
generations to pursue their dreams and
we are delighted to add our own
accolades to her honors
[Applause]
first and foremost given honor to my
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
for he has it if it was not for him I
would not be standing here today I would
like to thank I covered for taking the
risk in the time for nominating me for
this award and I would like to introduce
two very important people in my life my
mother mrs. Charlene Smith who
who exhibits who exhibits dignity and
showed me at a young age how to be
strong in adverse situations and not to
be afraid to speak up for what is right
I would like to also acknowledge my
father mr. Charles Jordan she Stan who
is a prayer warrior because prayer is
what's going to make a change I would
like to thank my other relatives who
have come here in the back like cousins
and this is nothing for all the support
that they've they've given me in the
people who are sitting at these two
tables Mary Roberts who's helped me in a
lot of ways she's just continuously be a
scientist
Tina Sanders Carmen Turner Joann stubby
who let me in her lab Rick Dan Heiser
who continues to have conversations to
try to change some things around here
Teresa O'Connor on the way out in the
morning kinda talks to me and keeps me
going and my pastor Reverend reasons who
we have to get on the phone a whole lot
and pray I'm you asked me to talk
president fest for a minute and a half
on the significance of what Martin
Luther King has done in my life office
of minority education I haven't
forgotten you Daniel I was good in your
staff JJ Jackson of course she's going
to kill me
Margo Tyler who is not here Blanche
starting the chemistry undergraduate
office and if I missed you it's not
because that I forgotten you it's just
because I'm a little nervous I want to
talk to you about three specific things
and I and excuse me if I go over a
little bit but I just it's this very
important that you understand that I do
not
take this lightly I'm not sitting here
on my own recognizance and think that I
have arrived based on something that I
have done alone this struggle that we
are going through consistently is one in
which I live deadly three basics things
that encompass my life as with every
morning when I get up is racism sexism
and transversing through social economic
background the most debilitating aspect
of racism is the low expectation which
is associated with your existence only
because the you of your skin is
different low expectation permeates
ignorance it permeates that your talents
are ignored it ignores to tell us that
you have and ignores the challenge that
your ancestors have and the bottom line
is that you are viewed as being inferior
that the society expects very little
from you and therefore when you are born
when you come out of the birth channel
you are already at a disadvantage
because you are not expected and the
thing about it is that you have to come
out fighting you have to come out
fighting and you do not have time to
investigate the origin of the fight the
only thing that you have to do is fight
how do you expect your child to do good
on a test how do you expect a child to
have self-esteem how do you affect just
expect a child to feel equal when we
already are doomed and equal only
because again I'd say the color of your
skin we had nothing to do with that
God is the one who decided where each
and every one of our souls would be
encompassed what would you do if you
were in the body of an african-american
female Hispanic male how would you feel
if you were treated as less than I to
share in Martin Luther King's dream and
I know that that fight also included
equality for women for I know how it
feels to be overlooked only because you
are a woman and to band with other women
and for them to not understand that when
they show discrimination against your
skin color that they are fighting
against the same fight that you and I
are fighting together that when you
ignore my skin and my gender either one
feels just as painful as the other it is
also painful when men of my same you
skin color forgets that I come from will
they come and they do not understand how
soon do you forget how soon did you
forget that it was a woman an
african-american woman who went back and
forth underground underground to free us
as slaves how soon you forget and if you
forget that don't you know that your
mother and your sisters and your
grandparents are two women that brought
you here through the loins of their
wounds I say I'm tired of being looked
at as a quilter
I am tired of people thinking that I
have only got where I am because I am
black and female they negate the effort
the hard nights the long hours the books
the tall the snare they don't think of
that they do not think of that finally
when you transverse the low social
economical background and you do the
right things and you pay the price and
you take the qualifies and you pass them
but you consistently over and over and
over and over again being re-evaluated
and really qualified and the bottom line
is that what it does for you is take you
away from what God has created you to do
to utilize your brain and your talents
to make a significant contribution to
society
I have sacrifice of family turn
Testament I have sacrificed children so
these children these young people in
which I meet all my children when I
share with them I share with them
inspiration so that they will be able to
make it on a day to day level so that
maybe they will not give up so when they
finally get to the trees that they are
obtaining and go to the rest job and
still not have access not have
opportunity to be able to not utilize
the resources that they would know that
they have to go deep within themselves
and pull from somewhere where it
sometimes is not the strength to
continue to fight so I would like I have
a dream
I have a dream that one day that one
time in this country that someone will
know that a brain knows no color that a
brain knows no gender that our brain
does not have money attached to it
that's my dream
I accept this award I accept this award
not because I am satisfied with my
accomplishments I accept this award not
because there's not more work to do I
accept this award as encouragement for
the future and impetus to continue to
nurture more people in the cadre of
individuals that you may not ever know
that have sacrificed their lives for me
to be standing here today Martin Luther
King was a Christian man he said love
your enemies I am learning how to love I
am learning how to love he was a
Christian man he said that science and
religion he states in his book is
strength to love that science and
religion are complementary and that
together they bring together wisdoms
facts power and values so for the young
people in the room I'm going to leave
you with this this comes from Isaiah the
fortieth chapter in the 31st verse and
it comes on the NIV version so it's
praying English and it says for those
who hope in the Lord for those who hope
in the Lord will renew their strength
was saw on though as the wings of eagles
they were Rhine and yet not get weary
and they will walk and yet not faint
thank you
[Applause]
our second award this morning goes to
miss Toby Winer
administrative assistant in the
Department of Political Science not only
does she serve as a mentor and a friend
to faculty and students alike she's
worked creatively and tirelessly to
organize and teach subjects on such
issues a social justice the history of
the civil rights movement and community
service in all of this she has worked in
thews e asta CLE and skillfully to
create an inclusive compassionate and
civic minded community here at MIT we
are fortunate to have her here we were
pleased to be able to recognize her many
contributions to life and to learning at
MIT would you please come up
[Applause]
first I want to say how honored I am to
receive this award this is truly one of
the most important events of my life I
want to thank the MLK committee and all
of the people at MIT who have supported
me through all my years here and there's
a lot of people and I won't mention them
but there are a lot of them out there in
the room tonight today so thank you very
much and finally I want to thank the
political science department I couldn't
have done any of the seminars classes
and activities that you're honoring me
here today for without the support
pretty much unconditional support of my
department and I'd really like to thank
Dan Crider for nominating me and just
everyone here thank you very much
[Applause]
our final 1998 Martin Luther King
Leadership Award goes to an exceptional
student an exceptional student who has
used his artistic talent as a
springboard for community building and
inclusiveness although still only in his
junior year he's already won several
notable awards for his painting and his
printmaking including the 1997 Liszt
Foundation fellowship in the arts his
high visibility and charisma have
enabled him to produce a number of
provocative and successful performing
arts events that have made significant
contributions to our cultural life many
of these activities have celebrated
black artists and have engaged them
directly in our community 800 - tick boo
class of 99 is an exceptional student
leader and we are delighted to recognize
him with this award Hey
[Applause]
first like to say that you all inspire
me Oh first is Jordan I feel you um
everyone as far as me
um someone asked me you know what you
what do you do to get that when I told
one of my friends I told him I survived
because I'm always Restless here because
I don't necessarily belong I'm not
necessarily comfortable here so to
survive I have to make a mighty my own
and my team and to do that I've done a
lot of different things I wanted to
explore art so I met the of the arts and
I got the list Foundation fellowship and
when I need support
I have a special person Kamla Topsy when
I need encouragement I have my comrades
27 brothers of mine Silas city I have my
memento I'd Wilma Clooney though office
minority education Dean Osgood and they
be saw addy survivors Harris
[Applause]
I'm gonna thank everybody in person on
some other time because they this is
very special to me and I just want to
leave this moment like this so thank you
very much
[Applause]
Thank You president vest and
congratulations to all the recipients
and now the pleasure of introducing dr.
Joel Moses Provost of MIT Provost Moses
will recognize the dr. Martin Luther
King jr. visiting professors for the
1997-98 academic year
Provost Moses
the Martin Luther King visiting
professor program was begun in 1994 in
the past three years the number of
visiting MLK visiting professors has
been as follows in 95 96 we had three in
academic year 96 97 we had five and the
current academic year we have seven I
therefore predict next year we'll have
nine just just kidding just kidding I
don't know how many but we have an
excellent group and five of this current
seven are here and I'd like to speak
about each and every one of them and
after I talk about them I hope they'll
be able stand up and and get an applause
you've already met Linda Jordan she's in
the Department of Chemistry she's an
associate professor in chemistry in
North Carolina agriculture and technical
State University and she received a PhD
in biological chemistry here at MIT in
1985 she is conducting research and
human placental phospholipase I hope I
pronounced that correctly and this
spring she is teaching 507 one in the
biochemistry laboratory please give her
another hand
Stephen Lee has been visiting the
department mathematics
he's a research staff member at the
mathematical sciences section of Oak
Ridge National Laboratory and an adjunct
assistant professor in the department of
computer science here here at the
University of Tennessee at Knoxville his
PhD is from University of Illinois and
his research has been in America
analysis and applications and last year
we renovated a number of ten classrooms
in the math building building two and
was my hope that the faculty in
mathematics would use computing
especially in a linear algebra course
and Steven Lee was the leader of that
effort and I hope it'll continue with
his help even now thank you very much
Pamela McAuley belt is with the
Department of aeronautics and
Astronautics she's also an assistant
professor industrial engineering and
management systems department at the
University of Central Florida and her
PhD is an industrial engineer for
University of Oklahoma at MIT she's
investigating the feasibility of fuzzy
set modeling as a technique to improve
the warning and alert systems in the irk
aircraft environment
[Applause]
Winston Saba Yahoo is jointly in the
mechanical engineering and material
science engineering departments is an
associate professor of the popular
material science and engineering at the
Ohio State University and a PhD from
Churchill College in Cambridge
University England and his research
focus is fatigue and fracture materials
and the development of advanced
materials and their composited professor
sub I am
and having arrived in the last five
minutes Louis Thomas is with the Sloan
School of Management he's an assistant
professor of management at the Wharton
School in the University of Pennsylvania
and his PhD from Harvard University in
business economics and his research
focus is an applied economics brand
management management of technology and
technological innovation professor
Thomas let me also mention this the ones
who have not here professor and Esther
Cortez Jr is with the department of
urban studies and planning
he's a Southwest Director of the
industrial areas foundations in Austin
Texas which is an institution founded by
Saul Alinsky in Chicago in the 1940s
provides leadership training for poor
and moderate-income family
enesta contends that you may have read
is one of the five winners of the
$250,000 Heinz Family Foundation awards
for civic and academic achievements and
he has been teaching courses on
community or organism organizing each
semester as well as during eiope this
year so would you give a hand to perfect
our Ted
and finally Kevin Kornegay has been with
the electrical engineering computer
science department he came in as an
assistant professor from the school of
Electrical and Computer Engineering at
Purdue University having received his
PhD from University of California at
Berkeley and some of his research is is
in high-temperature circuit design using
silicon carbide he has since he was here
in the fall and he has since become a
faculty member at Cornell University so
would you give him a hand too and thank
you very much thank you dr. Moses
president vest will now give some
remarks followed by an introduction of
this morning's keynote speaker attorney
Leslie Baskerville president best
last year I spoke on this occasion about
the looming attacks on affirmative
action like any good scientist or
engineer I cited data from MIT and
elsewhere to support the assertion that
affirmative action as a policy is just
beginning to bear fruit in the world of
advanced education and research and that
both here at MIT and in society as a
whole we had far more work to do
since that time however I have come to
believe that the focus on the goals of
affirmative action is increasingly being
lost to an escalating and not very
productive debate about the methods that
saddens me because they think that a
genuine understanding of these issues
must begin with a recognition that by
any measure of opportunity advancement
education or income women and minorities
have not yet been fully integrated into
the highest levels of America's economy
and civil society does that mean that we
should defend blindly each and every
action policy and process that has ever
been undertaken in the name of
affirmative action certainly not but
does it mean that we must continue to
use effective appropriate and vigorous
means to the end of this unjust state of
affairs and questionably it does that
calls for continuing discussion and
debate how do we get from there from
here to there but before we as a society
and as a local community discuss the
means of affirmative action can't we
accept together the ends it is intended
to achieve can't we agree that there is
an important problem here even if we
cannot agree on exactly the best means
to its solution if the opponents of a
fair
of action are not willing to acknowledge
this then in my view the debate is not
about affirmative action but about much
more fundamental issues of social
justice and societal goals the concerns
of justice are in this case squarely
aligned with the pragmatic attention to
the economic and social well-being our
nation grows more diverse with each
passing year members of minority groups
make up one quarter of our population
today they will make up well over a
third of our population within 20 years
in the post-industrial world knowledge
is the basis of economic achievement for
nations just as it is for individuals
the well-being of all America depends on
the educational achievements of all of
our citizens if we recognize and agree
on that principle then somehow I think
the debate can rightfully focus on the
best means to achieve a society marked
by economic and social justice
unfortunately I think that much of the
discussion of the last few years has
been clouded by rhetoric that obscures
rather than illuminates these issues if
we want to free ourselves from the
fierce polarization that has
characterized the national debate about
so many social issues we must all
abandon the use of such terms of
concealment and speak plainly I will go
first like many of my colleagues I help
shape and I strongly support the
Association of American Universities
statement on the importance of diversity
in university admissions that statement
talks about the immense value of
diversity and enriching and enhancing
the educational experience of all
students in attempting to describe the
advantage of diversity for the entire
community however we may have employed
however unconsciously our own
terms of concealment by this I mean that
we may not have made a strong enough
link between the promotion of diversity
the deliberate goal of expanding
opportunity to students from groups
which remain statistically
underrepresented in highest levels of
American life the extension of these
opportunities is a good thing an
important thing in fact a critical thing
in and of itself we should be more
forthright in asserting this and just as
we should be clear about all of our
reasons for supporting diversity so we
should examine some of the mercury
language that has been used to attack
movements toward affirmative action and
diversity and other policies designed to
promote and ultimately ensure the
diversity of our institutions let us
begin with that wonderful word quotas a
term that is used to suggest that a
certain number of people from targeted
groups will be admitted or promoted
regardless of their qualifications this
notion somehow seems still to persist
despite the general acknowledgement that
quotas are in the case of university
admissions unverified and unverifiable
programs and specific numerical goals
are explicitly rejected by the AAU and
its member institutions can we just stop
talking about a problem that doesn't
exist let's turn to another loaded word
preference if admissions committees and
officers were showing absolute
preference for women and minorities then
women and minorities would be admitted
out of all proportion to their
representation in society as a whole if
on the other hand preference means
giving positive consideration to any
factor other than grades and test scores
then surely an attack on preferences for
race or gender should apply to other
preferences or athletic achievement
community service artistic or musical
ability
or in the case of many schools but not
here at MIT
having alumni parents these forms of
preference are rarely attacked because
they are seen as part of a larger set of
criteria preferences thus another
misleading term which effectively
conceals the one factor among many one
factor among many approach to admissions
allowed by the Bakke decision while
subtly suggesting that minorities are
somehow over-represented in our
populations finally let me turn to that
most troubling of all of these terms of
concealment ultimately opponents of
affirmative action and admissions
complained that it results in the
acceptance of candidates who are
unqualified or just as ominous under
qualified what can we say to this we
could point out that this allegedly
under qualified manat that they
allegedly under qualified minority
students admitted to the University of
Texas law school did just as well at
passing the State Bar Exam as did their
white male counterparts or we could
point out that the allegedly under
qualified women admitted to MIT somehow
miraculously seemed to earn slightly
better grades than their white male
classmates we could point out the test
scores and grades provide a very
important threshold or benchmark measure
of potential but beyond a certain level
such measures cannot offer hard and fast
predictions of achievement for any of us
we could point out that every student
who is accepted to this institution is
well past that threshold of competence
and capability and is thus well
qualified to do the work I believe that
we should be making these points and one
more the ultimate test of any admission
policy or any other policy designed to
promote diversity should be its ability
to maintain standards of performance
broadening access and opportunity mi
t--'s graduates whatever their gender
race/ethnicity or test scores continue
to do extraordinarily well in their
fields they consistently reinforce mi
t--'s reputation as one of the greatest
universities in the world by the
pragmatic test of how our graduates
perform
I think our admissions policies
including those policies regarding
diversity have in fact been very
successful MIT and our society as a
whole should be willing to look at any
alternative policy which produces the
same or better results but no amount of
misleading rhetoric should confuse us
into accepting anything less by all
means we should perfect our tools and
refine our methods but we should never
turn away from the pressing task before
us we have achieved too much not to
stand our ground thank you very much
and now now it is my great pleasure to
introduce this morning's keynote speaker
Leslie Baskerville currently serves as
general counsel to the National
Association for Equal Opportunity in
higher education this Washington based
organization serves a vital public
advocacy and coordinating function for
117 predominantly black colleges and
universities both private and land-grant
institutions her work for the NEA feo is
only the latest chapter in a
distinguished career of public service
and political activism a graduate of
Rutgers University in Howard University
Law School she has service in her senior
congressional staff dinner
staff positions and worked in several
national political campaigns including
Reverend Jesse Jackson's presidential
runs in 1984 1988 and more recently in
1996 Clinton gore campaign she was the
founding director of the national black
leadership Roundtable a founding member
of the national political congress of
black women and is a founding board
member of the national rainbow coalition
we were very honored to have her with us
to share her reflections this morning
please welcome Miss Leslie Baskerville
Thank You president vest mrs. vest it's
been a powerful morning and I'm
privileged to be here just the powerful
morning and I want to thank Dean Osgood
and professor Feld the entire Martin
Luther King jr. committee for having me
here to partake in this powerful
powerful morning I thank you all and the
students especially the gospel choir the
awardees all of you have contributed to
making this an outstanding and memorable
morning for me I'm privileged to be here
this morning at this important center of
instruction academic research and social
service I'm gratified to join the good
people of MIT who have a symbol to honor
a noble fallen leader in the universal
movement for justice human dignity
freedom and equality I am privileged to
have been asked to join with you in
celebrating the meaning and the message
of an educator who taught about the
shield of justice and the sword of truth
an agent of change who helped to
transform the manner in which an entire
generation perceived of itself and of
its relationship to its fellow man we
meet to breathe new life and
contemporary meaning into the legacy of
an excavator who helped the nation to
dig from what king called the quicksand
of racial ethnic gender and economic
injustice to the solid rock of human
dignity
I most warmly embrace this opportunity
to help keep alive the evolutionary
movement of non-violent millicent
militancy to prod the nation to realize
its egalitarian ideals dr. King was a
revolutionary whose appeal to the
decency of Americans and their basic
values fueled arguably the most
successful revolution in our history the
civil rights revolution the revolution
helped the nation to loosen the shackles
of race prejudice and to topple a
pernicious system of legal segregation
that defied decency and fundamental
democratic values in the thirty years
since the death of dr. Martin Luther
King jr. the unstinting efforts of
people of many races and ethnicities
both genders varying abilities and
fortunes have yielded incremental
strides to redeem the country's promise
of equality of opportunity and justice
for all today despite the fact that
African Americans Hispanics American
Indians and other disfranchise groups
are not even within hailing distance of
equality there are visible signs that
the United States has become a more
perfect union
a more pluralistic nation witnessed the
tremendous rise in the number of African
American elected officials from less
than 1500 in 1970 to more than 8,000
today including mayors members of
Congress and a United States Senator
from Illinois there exist today
2,300 african-american women in elective
office one former african-american
governor and an African American who
waged a serious race
or the United States presidency and
another african-american whom polls
suggested that at least in their hearts
a greater number of Americans wanted to
be the president of the United States
than any other candidate or would-be
candidate for the office thanks to
federal anti-discrimination mandates and
affirmative action despite their
continued under representation in all
aspects of American life minorities that
were routinely excluded from schools
from professions corporate jobs uniform
public jobs and skilled trades now have
limited access in these avenues of
Economic Opportunity many minorities
have moved into the mainstream as it is
called there's a fledgling
african-american middle class that has
grown from 1 in 17 families a generation
ago to one in seven today and blacks
hold corporate and professional jobs
unheard of in the days when dr. King was
boycotting the buses in Montgomery
Alabama companies that hired minorities
only for janitorial work and women only
for clerical jobs now have minority and
female managers and universities that
would not admit African American and
Hispanic students now have black and
Hispanic administrators Dean Osgood and
professors as a result of affirmative
action the number of african-american
students in predominantly white colleges
and universities has grown from 134
thousand in 1961 to 1.2 million today
Equal Opportunity and affirmative action
laws spawned a cadre of professional
working women that have increased the
overall incomes of two-parent white
non-hispanic households but like their
racial and ethnic minority counterparts
white women face ceilings on their
aspirin
in 1995 their wages were just 73% of
white men's slowly eking up from 61% in
1967 in the fall of 1995 a bipartisan
National Commission concluded that the
glass ceiling is firmly in place
it found that 97% of senior managers of
Ford Fortune 500 companies are white and
almost all are male
it found that african-american men with
professional degrees earned 21% less
than whites holding the same degree in
the same job category and that
african-americans and women with college
degrees earn little more than white
males with a high school diploma the
Commission found that less than half of
1% of managers are Hispanic and that
asian-americans earn less than whites in
comparable positions and get fewer
promotions despite the fact that they
have more formal education than other
groups
no one can seriously believe that the
limited progress that has been made
toward opening previously closed areas
of our society and the dent that has
been made in the monopolies in high and
not so high places in America would have
been made were it not for affirmative
action not even Clarence Thomas who in
1983 during a soul-searching reflection
is reported to have said but for
affirmative action laws god only knows
where I would be today
of course today Justice Thomas
repudiates affirmative action despite
the data which suggests a continued need
for affirmative action why the flip-flop
on affirmative action on the part of
Justice Thomas and on the part of others
such as Senator Bob Dole who authored
the Americans with Disabilities Act
and supported other federal affirmative
action legislation until he sought to
jumpstart his last presidential campaign
why the change of position on
affirmative action when all indications
are that it is proving effective and
that there is a continued need for
affirmative action and why now is
affirmative action under siege after a
good start
did America simply grow weary with the
struggle for equal opportunity and put
it on the back burner or is there
something more pernicious afoot more
importantly will affirmative action
survive
I believe that affirmative action will
survive and I believe as I will
illustrate it will survive because it
works it is still needed and it benefits
all Americans the opponents of
affirmative action of course did not
agree they are pine that earmarking a
small fraction of positions in work
settings in educational institutions in
places of influence affluence and
prestige to end segregation therein runs
counter to fundamental principles of
equal opportunity and individual merit
opponents argue that taking special
efforts to assure that our students are
trained in leadership roles in public
life and in the professions in a
culturally rich diverse setting is
unamerican to the extent that achieving
such diversity requires the examination
of factors in addition to test scores
opponents postulate that affirmative
action is an illegal policy that accords
the beneficiaries special rights these
arguments are not new they are simply
the same old bone and make no bones
about it the arguments of the opponents
are cyclical and all those shrouded and
emotionally appealing verbiage and now
being advanced by a more diverse cast of
characters the
falls short especially in a university
setting where many considerations other
than test scores have affected and
continue to affect admissions at each
juncture in our history when the nation
has found itself in tenuous economic
circumstances it has opted not to
reorder its national priorities to
invest in human needs and human capital
but rather to adopt and implement
policies that profoundly and negatively
affect not only millions of Americans of
color but also the poor women the
vulnerable young workers the elderly and
the unemployed today is no exception
although the unemployment rates are low
and the gross domestic product is up
incomes are rising and Americans have
America has secured itself as the
world's premier economic power the
nation is reeling from the restructuring
downsizing merging and layoffs of the
70s and 80s moreover changes in
technology are making workers at all
levels more vulnerable to job loss new
markets abroad - are making us workers
vulnerable the vulnerability has created
insecurity and with good reason it is
reported that between 1979 and 95 the
United States lost more than 43 million
jobs one of the results of the job loss
is that in this time of prosperity we
are seeing a widening gap between those
whom we call the haves and the have-nots
William Julius Wilson profoundly makes
this point in his book the declining
significance of race but it is against
this backdrop that we once again find
ourselves facing the same old bone yet
another challenge to affirmative action
it is amid this uncertainty and
insecurity that people of color and
women are again being scapegoated for
the failings of the American market
economy the policies that were
instituted to solve problems have now
become the problem you may recall that
it was shortly after the collapse in
California of the defense industry and
the loss of numerous jobs associated
with that industry that proposition 209
surfaces its architects and the
architects of similar initiatives and
legislation across the country would
have the public believe that were it not
for people of color and women coming
into closed arenas in the labor force
the plant workers who were laid off
during the 80s and 90s would have job
security they would have the American
public believed that the mid-level
managers who fell to the acts of
efficiency experts would all have job
security and certain futures were it not
for affirmative action opponents of
affirmative action would have us believe
that unqualified black and brown
students are being accepted into leading
universities at the expense of more
qualified white students well despite
all the hoopla about minority
preferences at the University of
California Berkeley you should note that
prior to proposition 209 taking effect
the student population was only 6%
African American and 14% Hispanic what
that meant in real terms was that
roughly 80% of the seats were set aside
for white students all of whom did not
score well on standardized tests some of
the white students were the
beneficiaries of the 80% non-minority
admissions set aside at the University
of California at Berkeley where the sons
and daughters of alumni board members
philanthropists elected officials and
other persons of
power received affirmative action some
of the 80% were from a geographic region
of the country or a foreign country
which the university sought to seek
representation lacrosse players swimmers
tennis players runners and baseball
players were the beneficiaries of the
non-minority earmark in many instances
these athletes were admitted with low or
no academic promise if the standardized
test be the only gauge there were
musicians and students who speak
multiple languages and others that had
special factors that the university
sought to include to achieve a more
diverse student popular all given
preference under the remaining 80%
set-aside UC Berkeley also considered
what disciplines the students promised
to pursue it did not want all theater
arts majors special consideration for
admissions through one of the 80%
non-minority set-aside seats went to
veterans went to older Americans went to
persons with different physical
abilities who were seeking to overcome
societal limitations and students who
were able to pay full tuition and were
not in need of scholarships or grants
all of these factors are valid
admissions criteria and each is
important to maintaining a diverse
student population interestingly each
one of these considerations with the
exception of race ethnicity and gender
continues to be a factor in admissions
considerations at the University of
Berkeley and elsewhere in Hopwood versus
Texas that which was referenced by
president vest it was revealed that 100
white students with test scores lower
than the four plaintiffs were admitted
to the University of Texas law school
they this clearly suggests that there
was affirmative action in place for
non-minorities consideration was given
to other than the test-score for at
least the 100 white students who did not
fare as well as the plaintiffs but were
nonetheless admitted to the university
but no one challenged those policies no
one challenges the policies that Accord
affirmative action to persons on the
basis of other than race ethnicity and
gender
why do proposition 209 and pending and
proposed legislation as to race
ethnicity and gender as one of many
criteria in admissions to universities
but did not question age military status
relationship to alumni athletic ability
influence and wealth regional origins
and academic preference as admissions
criteria are the reasons for affirmative
action for alumni athletes the rich and
powerful students from select
undergraduate from underrepresented
regions and foreign countries not as
compelling as the reasons for
affirmative action that take into
account race ethnicity and or gender of
course not the reasons for affirmative
action for racial and ethnic minorities
and women in this country far outweigh
considerations and other areas
especially in a nation such as ours that
is grounded on an egalitarian ideal in
Bakke the Supreme Court found that race
ethnicity and gender are indeed valid
admissions considerations in the context
of higher education and despite judicial
retreat from Bakke by the Fifth Circuit
in hopwood the Bakke decision
fortunately remains the law of the land
today in other than an emotionally
charged setting where blacks and
Hispanics are pitted against whites or
conservative blacks are pitted against
more centrist or liberal blacks the
American population understand
and supports affirmative action recall
if you will the 1992 Bill Clinton
presidential campaign during his
campaign for the Democratic presidential
nomination
Bill Clinton promised that if he got the
nod he would appoint a cabinet that
looked like America no one questioned
that in fact he was applauded for
wanting to achieve a diverse cabinet as
President Clinton's search for qualified
persons to fill the cabinet position
neared an end and there were two
positions that had gone to women the
transition team encouraged President
Clinton to take a look at women for
additional positions the transition team
earmarked one of the remaining slots for
a woman a non-traditional slot that of
the United States Attorney General
Clinton's predecessor definitely chose a
younger running mate in an effort to woo
younger voters and before President Bush
President Reagan sought to appoint a
female to head the United States
Department of Labor with the exception
of President Clinton most all recent
presidential candidates have sought
running mates that were from or would
appeal to different geographic region
than they each one of these decisions
was an affirmative action decision each
was accepted and supported by the
American public each required searching
beyond the traditional selection pool
for qualified candidates that brought
something complementary into the pool
and in no case with the person selected
for the position have been selected if a
goal had not been established to look
beyond the old boys network to a
targeted utilized underutilized group
the goal was established for the purpose
of fending off an otherwise nearly
certain all white male appointment and
efforts were made to go out and find a
qualified person from among the targeted
groups this is affirmative action in
action and in this context the public
understands that diversity is a worthy
goal more importantly there was no
charge of reverse discrimination and
where goals have been established for
geographic diversity no assumption have
has ever been made that the candidates
from one region are necessarily inferior
to the candidates from another region
where diversity goals have been
established for older Americans for
veterans for persons who sign persons
who use a wheelchair and other persons
who have been left out of the main
access to our society no assumption is
made that the person from the targeted
group is necessarily inferior to others
this brings me to the gravamen of my
position I submit and the data support
that American public does not really
oppose affirmative action when cast in a
proper light and couched in appropriate
terms the public supports affirmative
action but the opponents of affirmative
action are not attempting to project
affirmative action as it really is and
the proponents of affirmative action
missed an early opportunity to do
something during this latest round of
assaults on affirmative action when
former Senator Bob Dole called for a
review of every federal statute
regulation program and executive order
that grants a preference to individuals
on the basis of race sex national origin
or ethnic background as the beginning
point for the unraveling of federal
affirmative action laws and regulations
the supporters of affirmative action
should have denounced the idea of
tampering with equal opportunity laws
all together but simultaneously said
senator dole if you insist on reviewing
affirmative action laws and if you
insist on unraveling affirmative action
review all of the affirmative action
laws and unravel all of the affirmative
action laws such as those laws that
require affirmative action for religious
minorities for Americans with
Disabilities older Americans Vietnam era
veterans and other groups for whom the
nation's laws require affirmative action
as for trade by detractors affirmative
action is a bonanza for racial and
ethnic minorities and women in reality
affirmative action is not simply action
to include racial and ethnic minorities
and women into areas from which they
have been and continued to be excluded
it is much much broader and in order to
stabilize affirmative action programs
and repeal opponents affirmative action
allies must set the record straight in
this regard while setting the record
straight that affirmative action is
broad and all-inclusive in society as it
has evolved we should not lose sight of
the fact that affirmative action is a
remedy and is the remedy for years of
invidious discrimination against racial
minorities in America the discrimination
has continued in large measure and vast
disparities exist in economic and
educational attainment as the result of
the discrimination affirmative action
became the pronounced policy in this
society of attempting to erase the
effects of past discrimination and
continuing discrimination in the 1960s
when there was overwhelming evidence as
it is today that african-americans and
other minorities throughout the country
are the victims of systemic invidious
discrimination in education in
employment in housing and virtually
every area of American life faced with
studies that revealed that
discrimination based on race remained
manifest in all walks of public life
despite previous previous efforts that
have been made to eliminate the
discrimination
Congress called for make-whole efforts
for victims of discrimination justice
blackmun in Bakke summarized what was
required most succinctly and clearly and
he stated thus in order to get beyond
racism we must first take account of
race there is no other way and in order
to treat some persons equally we must
treat them differently we cannot and we
dare not let the Equal Protection Clause
perpetuate racial supremacy these words
are as true today as they were when
written to many African Americans
Hispanics and Native Americans are
growing up in poverty in crime and drug
infested neighborhoods attending
underfunded inferior schools and we
cannot believe that the students from
these environments can adequately
compete for a job score or a score on a
10th for a job or a score on a
standardized test years ago President
Lyndon Johnson said you do not take a
person who for years has been hobbled by
Chains and liberate him bring him to the
starting line of a race and then say
you're free to compete with all the
others and justly believe that you have
been fair you could not then and you
cannot today anyone who believes that we
are today a colorblind society in which
everyone enjoys equal opportunity is
sadly mistaken and cannot see we are far
from a colorblind society and to the
extent that color remains a criterion
for consideration in awarding the spoils
of the nation it too must be a
consideration in a remedial plan
the invidious treatment of
african-americans and Hispanics is not
however a winning argument in the debate
on firm ative action it's not the
strongest argument the strongest
argument for affirmative action in
America is that as it has evolved
affirmative action covers the vast
majority of Americans as it has evolved
affirmative action is no longer a remedy
for the atrocities visited upon the
ancestors of African American slaves
Hispanic Americans Indians and women are
covered by affirmative action laws but
affirmative action is much broader than
this persons are protected based on
religion veteran status disabling
condition or the status as an older
American which is defined as anyone over
40 the Vietnam errors' veterans
readjustment Act for example requires
affirmative action the Rehabilitation
Act of 1973 requires affirmative action
the Americans with Disabilities Act of
1990 requires affirmative action the Age
Discrimination in Employment Act and its
enabling legislations
require affirmative action in short the
majority of Americans are now covered by
affirmative action laws and supporters
of affirmative action that want to when
this debate must begin to articulate
this position if for example California
ended affirmative action as relates to
racial and ethnic minorities and women
equity dictates that the state eliminate
affirmative action for veterans older
Americans and persons with disabilities
all of whom continue to have affirmative
action preferences in the state of
California
let me be clear I support and I
encourage all infirmity firm ative
action I encourage every effort to
include persons in the main line of our
society we need and we want affirmative
action for all groups that have been
denied access to the nation's
institutions programs and activity but
as a strategy if we link affirmative
action programs as colloquially used
with the affirmative action programs for
other groups it becomes more difficult
to maintain opposition to affirmative
action for example I presume that the
Americans with Disabilities Act is not
the only affirmative action legislation
that Bob Dole still supports my guess is
that septuagenarian Dole also supports
affirmative action for older Americans
my guess is that veteran Dole does not
oppose affirmative action requirements
for disabled veterans and veterans of
the Vietnam era nor probably does he
oppose veterans preference legislation
and regulations it is imperative for the
proponents of affirmative action for
racial ethnic and religious minorities
and women to provide for the legislators
administrators judges justices and
others who will make final decisions on
the issue of affirmative action a stake
in the debate these persons are mostly
older white men many of whom served some
time in the military and may be disabled
once the decision makers in the
affirmative action debate are made to
understand that they too are more than
simply tangential stakeholders in the
debate and once we halt the decoupling
of race ethnicity and gender from age
disability and veteran status I believe
that we can begin to ward off the latest
rounds of firm ative action we must
repel assailants of affirmative action
as we engage in the affirmative action
dialogue as we discuss what affirmative
action is and as we begin to recover
race ethnicity and gender with veteran
status age and physical disabilities we
have to be clear what affirmative action
is not affirmative action is not a quota
as commonly Luke used affirmative
actions are remedial measures for years
of invidious discrimination that
continues today and I've discussed that
earlier
they include efforts to seek out and
include to train to promote those who
have been excluded because of their race
ethnicity and gender for sure but also
because of their religion their
disabling condition their age or
military status affirmative action is
not admitting or hiring unqualified
persons permit of action may mean
redefining qualified so that non
relevant criteria criteria having little
or no bearing on the likelihood of
success of a meritorious candidate must
be eliminated such as certain height and
weight requirements parents of alumni
status friendship to employees
affirmative action should mean that
diversity in a workforce and in an
educational institution is considered as
a valuable asset in the field of higher
education race ethnicity and gender
affirmative action has never meant
allowing students to get by because of
the color of their skin or their sex
once admitted to colleges and
universities the students who are
admitted under an affirmative action
program for underrepresented minorities
or for women do not receive affirmative
action greens in many instances a
hostile environment awaits them and they
must work twice as hard to receive an A
they must work twice as hard to receive
access to the resources the professor's
the TAS
and those things which other students
find in a warm and welcoming environment
on a predominantly white campus those
who got in because of affirmative action
do not get by on affirmative action and
we must articulate this clearly and
unequivocally despite some progress
toward fair access that has been made
since the 1960s
we're not anywhere near close to
achieving a society in which a person's
race gender or ethnicity does not matter
the higher education statistics belie
the notion that there is no longer a
need for affirmative action according to
Census Bureau statistics in 1996 Council
on Education report in a 1995 Economic
Policy Institute survey African American
enrollments in colleges and universities
has increased by 16 percent since 1990
as of 1995 13% of African Americans 25
and older had a bachelor's degree which
was up from 11.3% in 1990 Hispanic
enrollment in colleges and universities
increased by 35 percent between 1990 and
1995 but despite this progress African
Americans American Indians and Hispanics
remain underrepresented particularly in
math science and engineering
despite their capacity and their desire
to master these subjects for example
while these groups collectively comprise
22 percent of the American population
they earned only 12% or 44,000 of more
than 366,000 math science and
engineering baccalaureate degrees
awarded to United States citizens and
permanent residents in 1993 parity for
these groups would have required them to
earn 80,000 plus degrees almost twice as
many math science and engineering
degrees as were actually awarded the
statistics abound
not bore you with them but particularly
in math science and engineering
under-representation remains manifest
with african-americans receiving less
than 1% of higher educated degrees in
math science and engineering and we've
got to do something to reverse this tide
these data suggest that in higher
education as in other arenas affirmative
action is working but there's still a
lot left to be done to close the gap it
is essential that goals and timetables
be established maintained and enforced
for including african-americans and
Hispanics in growth-oriented degree
granting programs it is essential to
that financial assistance may be made
available including minority targeted
scholarships which despite some District
Court decisions remain the law of the
land and it is imperative that other
forms of support systems be put in place
to retain and assist students who are
admitted under affirmative action
programs despite these statistics and
comparable data on other areas in which
affirmative action is being taken we're
hearing the same old bone that
affirmative action is hurting Society
and its intended beneficiaries just as
Thomas and Shelby Steele other opponents
of affirmative action opine that
affirmative action stamps minorities and
women with badges of inferiority and
creates a hostility and resentment that
leads to further racial separation
relative to the badges of inferiority
argument is noted earlier effective
affirmative action programs do not allow
for the selection of unqualified
candidates the programs allow for a
reassessment of merit so that white male
status is not giving overwhelming
favorable weight and diversity given no
consideration
it also requires employers and
admissions directors to
consider a wider range of measurements
for likelihood of success than for
example a test score thus anyone who is
admitted or hired under an affirmative
action program should be presumed to be
qualified for the position and not
inferior to any other meritorious
candidate and if such assumption is not
made the easiest way to dispel the
notion of the lack of qualification is
for the beneficiaries to excel once
accorded access the changing economy and
the changing racial and ethnic makeup of
the labor force dictate that in order
for the United States to maintain a
competitive advantage in the next
century government's educational
institutions and corporations must do
all that they can to assure that
underrepresented minorities get the
skills and the know-how to exceed as
President Clinton said from the lawn of
the old Statehouse in Little Rock
Arkansas on November 5th 1997 whether
you belong to the party of Lincoln the
party of Jefferson whether you're
independent or unaffiliated remember
that most of all you belong to the
community of America we're all in this
together we will rise or we will fall
together living out these words is our
greatest challenge and our greatest
opportunity this is our task our charge
to keep our calling to fulfill our
rendezvous with destiny to weave into a
marvelous tapestry the many people's
colors and traditions called America to
do this we must celebrate diversity
while bringing people together as we all
know the task is not easy but we should
be better equipped for the current
challenges to an open and pluralistic
society we should be better armed in the
present war against affirmative action
for it is simply the same old bone as we
rise up to leave this celebration of the
life and legacy of dr. Martin Luther
King jr. recall with me his stirring
baritone voice on the eve before his
death calling upon us to rise up rise up
with a greater readiness stand with a
greater determination move on in these
powerful days these days of challenge to
make America a better nation thank you
[Applause]
Thank You attorney Baskerville I will
now continue with some announcements
regarding several events which will be
occurring this weekend the Martin Luther
King jr. celebration committee will be
sponsoring a Youth Conference on
Saturday February 14th with registration
beginning at 9:30 a.m. at the MIT little
Kresge Auditorium the committee will
also be sponsoring a musical tribute to
dr. King on Saturday the 14th at 8 p.m.
in MIT Kresge Auditorium both are free
and open to the public if you will now
please turn to the back of your programs
you will find the words to lift every
voice and sing by James Weldon Johnson
please rise and join the MIT gospel
choir in singing one verse of the song
lift every voice and sing till the
panhead garnering ring with the
harmonies of Liberty let our rejoicing
rise high as the listening skies let it
resound loud as a rolling see sing a
song full of the feedback thuds our
pastor store
does sing a song full of the hope that
the president's war
photos they sing the right let us march
on till victory
[Applause]
Thank You Aaron winters and the MIT
Gospel Choir for your beautiful music
this morning I would like to ask
Reverend Jane Gould to offer the
benediction as we close this morning
celebration
Reverend Gould
caring within us the words and witness
of dr. Martin Luther King jr. of Leslie
Baskerville Michonne Donelson Cassandra
Strudwick Linda Jordan Toby whiner 808
hit Higby may we go forth from this
place holding in our hearts and minds
the call of the prophet Micah to do
justice to love kindness and to walk
humbly with our God amen Thank You
Reverend gold I hope you've all enjoyed
this morning celebration of the life and
legacy of dr. Martin Luther King jr. it
has been a wonderful and inspiring event
and we look forward to seeing you all
next year as we celebrate the 25th
anniversary of this great event thank
you and have a great day
[Applause]